so after his event with women
where he made the big announcement that
he's pardoning
susan b anthony who's been dead for
almost 120 years
trump did another event in yuma arizona
and
this was really a house of horrors
donald trump came out of his plane
and his first statement was right away
that because he caught sleepy joe spying
on him
which is treason he should get another
four years
on top of the four years he's seeking
now take a look at this
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
and you know considering that we caught
president obama and sleepy joe biden
spying on our campaign treason will
probably
be entitled to another four more years
after that
now i know when trump does this a lot of
people say david this doesn't even
deserve attention
because he won't get a third term of
course he won't
of course he won't but what deserves
attention
is that his followers buy into this
stuff they are so
easily convinced that hey yeah it was
unfair trump should get a third term
because of obama and biden despite it
all being made up and it all being
ridiculous
and this one got bad very very quickly
this next clip
might be the top instance of projection
that i've seen from donald trump
saying the biden campaign is cult-like
if you can imagine that we're talking
about abolishing prisons
biden's campaign has turned into a cult
for open border and other zealots
by the way they want to double and
triple your taxes
trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach and alcohol to treat coronavirus
and many of his followers stood behind
him saying you know maybe it's not such
a bad idea
and trump says the biden campaign is
like a cult
yeah the biden campaign has fallen for
the cult
of prioritizing democracy and competence
in the oval office that's the biden cult
that we have
there's actually a lot that's
interesting here and so
first there's the projection which with
trump is huge he often accuses others
of that which he himself is guilty of or
he accuses
the followers of biden of that which
his followers actually are guilty of but
also
the cult-like nature of trump's
followers
is a topic of academic inquiry it's not
just oh
trump says biden followers or cultists
but
trump's own followers are really the
cultists this has been studied
academically we interviewed cult expert
stephen hassan
about cults and how the trump
uh i don't i'm looking for a word other
than cult to say it's like occult
the the base of trump is very
cult-like so the projection is
particularly acute here
and then donald trump suggests that were
it not for him
we might not have the second amendment
right now the second amendment would be
gone if trump weren't president
and she's running against a gentleman
who is uh
when you read what he's done when you
read what he said about
the second amendment and about all other
things you're not going to want to vote
for them
you're not going to want to have them
play with your second amendment
i'll tell you what if i weren't
president i don't believe doug you'd
have a second amendment right now i
don't think it
the pressure that was put on this is
also
another one of these uh features or bugs
depending on how you look at it of
donald trump's personality issues
this is a delusion of grandeur right the
second amendment of the constitution has
been around since 1791 it's been 229
years
it has nothing to do with donald trump
it remaining doesn't require donald
trump
to get rid of it you would need a new
amendment and that just would not happen
there's just a
the the second amendment is completely
safe and trump has nothing to do with it
being safe
and then right in the middle of a
xenophobic
racist rant about murderers and killers
trump short circuits right in the middle
of the word removals that thing
happened where he glitches on a word and
his right shoulder spasms you have to
watch it
to understand it let's take a quick look
in facilities
this would make removing illegal aliens
totally impossible
and you would have murderers killers
rapists in your midst i don't think so
immediately suspend all removal
triggering a tidal wave of
really a flood if you think a flood so
anyway
every day trump doing some kind of event
like this clearly
not liking the dnc and the attention
that joe biden is getting
and each event is worse than the
previous more embarrassing and the
really embarrassing thing
on top of trump uh uh it's
doing these events is that no matter
what trump says
there's always a crowd that will cheer
for it it doesn't matter how absurd
how ridiculous how unconstitutional
trump can always get a group of
supporters together he can find a group
no matter what that will cheer for
anything he says and that's the really
scary part
because when we step back and we say
what has happened to the country over
the last three and a half years
what is the future of the country trump
is one person
when you find 63 million people to vote
for it
that's the real indictment of the
country and as i said before
if trump wins he'll probably win with
around 65 or 66 million votes
if trump loses in november
he will lose with likely between 60 and
65 million votes
and even if he is not the president
starting on january 20th
those 60 plus million people who are
going to vote for him
they still will live here they will
still be a problem that we have to
contend with and
i won't redo that analysis because i i
did it recently enough
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic
spoon who have done something awesome
they've taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman's show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n